Speaker 1: So part of me wishes I had something
positive and inspiring to start with on what
could be such a beautiful holiday week here
in the United States, Thanksgiving coming up
later this week. Unfortunately, I don't. I have
something potentially very negative. But one of
the things that I've always said I want to
do on this program is I don't want to go
overboard with hyperbole about something being
bad. But I also don't want to understate when
something is potentially not looking good. Let's
accurately evaluate how 2022 and subsequently 2024
is looking for Democrats and for the left, to the
extent that the left is functioning or operating
within the Democratic Party at this time. And
unfortunately, Democrats are facing a historic,
disastrous defeat in 2020 to above and beyond
even what is typical in the first midterm after
a different party has grabbed the White House. Our
friend of multiple time former guest on the show,
political scientist Rachel Beter Coffer, is
sort of sounding the alarm on this and saying,
Listen, it. It doesn't have to be
that bad for Democrats in 2022,
but Democrats need a plan which is currently
completely lacking, so we're going to talk
about that. But at this point, I'm comfortable
telling you that if we accurately evaluate
all of the factors at our disposal right now,
2022 could be a complete and total disaster for
Democrats, the likes of which Democrats don't
recover from for multiple election cycles.
And then we add to that, as we mentioned
last week, that aside from flipping seats,
fighting races on redistricting alone, Democrats
could lose a handful of seats in the House
of Representatives. So I encourage people to
kind of just set the stage for this. Read the
article by Chancey de Vega in Salon, which we're
linking to on YouTube by Rachel Bitter Coffer.
About what 2022 could be looking like. Rachel
Bediako coffer is very, very scared about what's
going on, and chancy accurately kind of gives us
a number of the important points here. Of course,
with the November election results of a couple
of weeks ago as one data point. The reality that
Democrats don't really seem to have a strategy
right now other than to continue running on, we're
not Trump. And of course, Trump is gone. And that
did not work very well in Virginia. And there's a
great conversation with Rachel Bedard coffer
here, where she is asked What are the errors
being made by Democrats? And she says, first
understand the following about the outcome in
Virginia a year before basically on the night of
the 2020 election, when it was clear Biden had won
the enthusiasm advantage for Republicans
was predictable. Republicans were going to
be out of power, which meant they were going to
get enthusiastic and engaged, and they are as
stupid as this whole. Let's go, Brandon. Thing is
it's it's working as an engagement rallying cry
for the sort of dumb, dumb right, as we might call
it. Rachel goes on to say Democrats were going to
be in power, which meant Democratic voters were
going to tune out and participate less. That seems
to be happening. Where that vote was going to
disappear was always predictable. The Democratic
Coalition ebbs and flows in terms of turnout.
Some of those voters are going to be Democrats,
others independents who tend to vote Democrats.
Certain demographics where this ends to happen
tends to happen in terms of turnout, such as
younger voters and minorities. The Democrats
know where they need to focus. You build an
infrastructure around the weakest parts of the
coalition, not from the top down, but the bottom
up. Even with all of this knowledge ahead of time,
the Democrats are not running elections using
that information or redesigning how redesigning
how they run election campaigns to build on the
realities of the electorate and the impact of
polarization and hyper partizanship. Meanwhile,
Republicans are running a fine tuned machine right
now, watching the Democrats and Terry McAuliffe
team was basically like watching somebody perform
algebra without having multiplication as a
skill set. It's not about just saying, Hey,
Youngkin is like Trump, it's about making
an association. Young man is like Trump.
Trump is the Republican Party. The Republican
Party is Trump. This matters to you. Why? Because
it's going to impact you negatively. This is a key
part. What the Republicans did with critical race
theory was packaged it through the emotion
about parental control over education.
They used it as a proxy. It's not really
about critical race theory, because remember,
critical race theory is not even being taught in
Virginia. It's a stand in for a challenge in white
privilege and whether white parents want their
kids to feel guilty for being white. It doesn't
matter if a random Republican can define what CRT
is. Remember, they can't. He knows what it means.
The Republicans knew what that man
would know when they used the language.
Critical race theory means we're going to protect
you from having to feel guilty about being white
and for your kids, having to feel guilty, for
being white, for having your white had demonic
power challenged in this more diverse America.
Now there's other stuff in this article about
Are Democrats bad at politics? Not really our
subject for discussion here. I don't believe
this is hyperbolic from Rachel Burdick offer,
and I also think this is such a unique situation
with such a huge potential for disaster that
the risk is asymmetrical. And so the strategy
has to be asymmetrical as well, what do I mean by
that? Some of you who have had like basic stats
know about expected value,
right? If I tell you flip a coin
and if it's heads, you get nothing. And if it's
tails, you get $100. Mathematically, the expected
value of that flip is $50. But there's no outcome
where you actually get $50, you get zero or 100,
but statistically you have an expected value
of $50 if you have a 10 sided die that you
roll and the outcomes are if you roll a one,
you get a dollar. If you wrote a roll of four,
you get $4, right. The expected value for the
average rolling five, even though the reality is
you might get one, you might get 10. Now with
this twenty twenty two twenty twenty four stuff.
Even if the outcome of total blowout
disaster for Democrats is only 10 percent.
It would be so disastrous that you need to go
above and beyond the expected value thought
process when you look at it and you say, Well,
I should assign as much effort to preventing
the one out of 10 scenario or the one out of 20
scenario based on its mathematical likelihood,
you're understating how disastrous it would be.
It would be such a disaster for Republicans to do
as well as Rachael points out that you actually
need to over prepare for it because the risk is
asymmetric or asymmetrical. And I think Rachel bit
of coffer is rightly sounding the alarm on that.
We're going to delve much deeper early in twenty
two into Senate, House and governorships. But
those who are understating and saying, Well,
you know, New Jersey governorship was no big
deal because oftentimes Democrats just straight up
lose and Phil Murphy won, even if by a little bit.
So that's not that bad, and it's not looking that
bad in the house. There's a scenario that's coming
together, which is maybe not the predominant
scenario, but it's a plausible scenario
that is potentially a 10 year disaster for
Democrats and for the left in the United States.
And I think it's a good thing that people like
Rachel better coffer are sounding the alarm on it.